In this last lesson of the course, you're going to be introduced to some real
life examples. That can be described mathematically by exponential growth,
exponential decay, and logarithmic growth. Now you've already seen the
equations that correspond to each of these types of functions before, so I'm
just going to refresh you on them. These forms I've written here may be
slightly different than what we've talked about. Note for example, that our
bases for our two exponential functions are e, and the base for our log
function is 10. So this is just one way of expressing these types of functions.
The question is, do you remember what each of these two functions looks like?
So to jog your memory on that, here are three graphs. I've labeled them A, B
and C and I'd like you to tell me which one corresponds to each of these types
of functions.